the banking industry is innovating at an
unprecedented pace and born in the cloud
digital disruptors are encroaching on
the market
but it can be disruptive and expensive
to implement new digital platforms
i'm catherine harrison product manager
at ibm
we're going to take a look at how ibm
cloud packs and ibm financial services
workbench can help banks speed
modernization by adding intelligent
integrated automation to the loan
decisioning process and by developing
composable banking solutions
in our example the cio of fictitious
vault spray bank needs to scale reduce
costs and deliver technology that can
speed up the small and medium enterprise
lending process per her business
requirements to stay competitive
to accomplish this she needs to create
business capabilities that are
independent of a dedicated channel and
platform architecture
so she asks michael the lead i.t
architect to establish the standards for
this new use case
michael explores ibm financial services
workbench a solution development and
composition suite designed to accelerate
development of modern cloud native
solutions
ibm financial services workbench lets
the team compose business solutions
rather than code them it does this by
the reuse of the inclusion of third
party or the creation of new domain
services
the freedom to compose solutions
protects past investments in existing
business capabilities it enables
best-of-breed solutions and it allows
phased modernization of existing
applications
developing cloud native is exciting but
the relevant skills can be scarce or
committed to other projects
michael starts with a solution designer
and creates a low code project
supporting the domain driven design
approach
this allows them to directly map
artifacts like aggregates command
services or events within the
collaborative design tool and to have
his business logic implemented in a low
code way thanks to code generation
support the developers can focus on
business logic and deliver the required
set of microservices with enterprise
grade quality in the very first
iteration
instead of independently deploying
individual services michael wants to
establish consistency and
standardization from the beginning
ibm financial services workbench offers
an operating model for building cloud
native solutions with a set of best
practices that unifies git deployment
management and monitoring all michael
needs to do is create a new application
composition project in ibm financial
services workbench
after defining a new deployment target
michael adds the previously implemented
components by simply selecting them from
the catalog once he is done with the
application composition a simple commit
triggers the deployment to the cluster
fully audit proof and automated thanks
to end-to-end ci cd pipelines and get
workflows applied to both operations and
development they now have the backbone
for their mvp a composition of reusable
business capabilities now we see the
business process being created in the
business automation workflow in ibm
cloud pack for business automation
all the new business capabilities are
available for direct consumption in a
low code environment and the required
tasks are easily mapped to roles and
teams
the business users love the integrated
experience where they can easily
interact with the work list and the
composed experience supporting task
completion and see all relevant
information in one consolidated view
there's no more searching for
information in other systems
the team now shifts focus to data-driven
decision support
using odm decision model capabilities
the customer's contextual information is
evaluated against configurable business
thresholds
once the new decision automation is
integrated into the ibm financial
services workbench service domain the
functionality is directly available in
all applications
the team uses appconnect and ibm cloud
pack for integration to securely connect
the existing environment and various
cloud systems without writing a single
line of code
the new integration flow is then
composed into the customer domain using
ibm financial services workbench
to get both recommendations and reliable
decisions the team now augments the
rules-based loan approval decisioning
model with a predictive machine learning
model
mina the data scientist uses ibm cloud
pack for data's auto ai capability to
develop and train a predictive machine
learning model to recommend whether a
loan should be approved or declined
so here's what we've seen
ibm financial services work benches
application composition framework
maximize reusability for vault spray
bank's team by allowing them to design
and build generic service domains rather
than product or channel specific
capabilities
the team delivered their solution ahead
of schedule because all roles could
collaborate
they were able to minimize day two
operations expenses because all the
solution components run on one platform
based on red hat open shift and can be
run in any cloud
they're saving time and money and
reducing risk and disruption because
they've progressively converged the
management of existing systems with a
new digital platform
we've used ibm's cloud packs and ibm
financial services workbench to apply
intelligent automation to a process that
spans multiple systems all under a
common control plane helping lenders set
a solid competitive advantage in this
rapidly changing market
you